INTERVIEWER: You learned
English in Colombia
or in the United States or--
Watching TV, man.
INTERVIEWER: Watching TV?
Watching TV,
hiding all the time.
My name is Sebastián Marroquín,
formerly Juan Pablo Escobar.
I am the son of Pablo Escobar.
I grew up living a life full
of money, full of power.
My father at the time,
he was perhaps one
of the richest men in Colombia.
I realized very early that he
was a bandit because he told
me when I was seven years old.
So you can imagine,
being a child,
perhaps you know the
meaning of the word bandit.
But you don't realize
how huge the organization
was that my father
was in charge of.
REPORTER: Pablo Escobar
has been identified
by American authorities
as Colombia's
leading exporter of cocaine.
The Escobar family has
reportedly amassed nearly $2
billion smuggling 1,100
pounds of refined cocaine
into the United
States every month.
SEBASTI N MARROQU N: We
were living in a life
that we felt power was endless.
EXPERT: The Medellín Cartel was
very rough, very vindictive.
The Cali people,
they looked at it
more as a business to expand.
[speaking in spanish]
SEBASTI N MARROQU N:
The Cali cartel
took control of all the Medellín
cartel routes in New York.
And that make my
father very upset.
MAR A ISABEL SANTOS:
[speaking in spanish]
SEBASTI N MARROQU N:
The Mónaco building
was our our family home.
We used to live there.
But I started to be so
aware of the consequences
of my father's
actions because I was
forced to hide more than he.
He was more free than--
than I was in that time.
[siren]
[speaking in spanish]
[boom]
[crash]
[sirens]
MAR A ISABEL SANTOS:
[speaking in spanish]
REPORTER: [speaking in spanish]
And my father became
even more crazy than ever
because he felt for one
hour that all of his family
were dead.
[speaking in spanish]